digamos que hemos estado trabajando con
cierto escenario
durante varios días en promedio hemos
estado consiguiendo un conejo pero 280
bayas digamos que estamos como en un
humor muy de bayas así que de repente
queremos cambiar nuestro borde hacia
otro tipo de alimentación entonces
déjenme escribir que del escenario que
quedamos estamos en un modo y queremos
pasar algo más proteínico digamos que
tratamos de capturar más conejos así que
tengo que hacer
si yo capturó un conejo más digamos un
conejo más
a la que estoy sacrificando entonces
digamos que aumentó un conejo en
promedio a dos conejos al día así que
estoy pasando del escenario al de ok
aquí sumamos uno bueno aquí voy a tener
que ceder 40 bayas verdad aquí lo puede
uno visualizar si yo intento obtener un
conejo más es no me puedo ir a la zona
de las cosas imposibles así que tengo
que quedarme en la frontera de las
posibilidades de producción a veces lo
abre veamos así fpp pero bueno si yo
quiero un conejo más es posible la
frontera de posibilidades de producción
acá de verdad y tengo que ceder 40 bayas
así que un conejo implica ceder en
promedio por supuesto 40 bayas
y el término técnico para lo que acabo
de describir es el costo de oportunidad
de cambiar un conejo
y que sería donar o ceder 40s vayas
verdad este es el costo de oportunidad
de un un conejo más
y este es el caso particular del
escenario de verdad como vimos y lo que
vamos a cambiar dependiendo del
escenario bueno al menos para este
ejemplo bueno el costo de oportunidad es
de un de un conejo son 40 bayas
suponiendo que estamos en el escenario
de un conejo más implica que tengo que
ceder 40 bayas y otro término que
utilizamos para el costo de oportunidad
digamos de producir digamos
el costo de oportunidad de producir un
conejo más cuando hablamos en este
sentido es a veces también llamado el
costo marginal así que este de aquí
también lo pueden ver como el costo
marginal
en este contexto del vídeo nuestros
costos están en términos de lo que estoy
cediendo verdad la oportunidad de
producir un conejo en otros escenarios a
lo mejor veremos que el costo marginal
puede ser dado en unidades monetarias de
por ejemplo producir una unidad extra de
algún artefacto solo hay que tratar de
entender de qué estamos hablando con el
costo marginal así que digamos para esta
situación estamos hablando de conejo
pero cuál es el costo de oportunidad por
ejemplo de volvernos completamente
vegetarianos estando en el en el
escenario así que digamos estamos en ley
queremos saltarnos shalev esencialmente
es comer ningún conejo y solo bayas ok
este sería por ejemplo el costo de
oportunidad
costo de oportunidad d
para hacer esto más fácil digamos de
obtener 20 unidades más de bayas
es bueno y voy a acceder un conejo voy a
hacer un conejo así que lo que estamos
viendo aquí es
quiero incrementar mis bayas por 20
unidades bueno pero tengo que disminuir
mis conejos en una unidad así que el
costo de oportunidad de 20 bayas es un
conejo
es un conejo ahora esto de aquí no es un
costo marginal porque estoy hablando de
20 unidades no sólo de una ok
lo que quiero es escribir esto en
términos del costo marginal que es de
una valla verdad bueno entonces
simplemente podemos dividir ambos lados
por 20 y tendremos que una valla una
valla más
es digamos suponiendo que esto para no
entrar en muchas cosas técnicas esto es
suponiendo que es lineal verdad pero
bueno esto sería un veinteavo de conejo
un veinteavo de conejo eso sí voy una
una valla más sitiando me en él en el
escenario ve en promedio voy a tener que
ceder un conejo perdón una un veinteavo
de conejo entonces cuando lo escribo en
esta forma esto sí es el costo marginal
perfecto ahora para aquellos que quieren
meterse un poquito más en la técnica
esto es una curva esto podría no ser tal
cual como lo dije porque bueno requiere
que sea lineal la curva verdad pero
bueno para fines de este ejemplo el
costo de oportunidad de 20 bayas es un
conejo pero si lo suponemos digamos
lineal de alguna forma y no curva bueno
el costo de oportunidad de una valla
desde un veinteavo de conejo
ok
básicamente es eso y lo podemos hacer
para distintos puntos en la curva de
hecho te invito a que lo hagas basado en
las observaciones que hicimos en el
último vídeo que pienses cuál es el
costo de oportunidad en cada uno de los
escenarios digamos si estás en el
escenario ve y quieres un conejo extra
más cuánto cuál es el costo en términos
de bayas ok o si quieres más bayas cuál
es el costo que tienes en términos de
conejos